mylan stop hopping on the kickball this
microphone you see that that's the sex
toy everything's a sex toy yeah I think
I'll be good at guessing what these are
we have not used a choice together
I see I'd say our sex life is full and
vibrant do I add into that - this
morning
[Music]
[Laughter]
sexual pawns psychedelic the chess set
this you like shut up and then you you
know what these are
woody clothes if I was drunk enough only
on Thursdays if he did it with me I
would do it so I was accepted Bobby
don't do that don't do that hi Wow Wow
the trailer goes here mr. hitch this
will hang somebody from where you hang
the person up by their butt
those people can vote get on the door
put you on a door screaming now now
close the door if I was like trying to
get like government secrets out of her
maybe this is like the torture man you
sit on these at work for your ab workout
oh [ __ ] reveal you built the inner
thighs and now you've been hit it like
bang this one goes inside a vagina
this one goes into the blood yeah nope
that's what that's for bang I think he's
pretty cute well what is this like a
mortar and pestle honestly I could curl
this put your dick in there or you put
your balls in there yeah why would you
put balls in here how do you fit both of
them in they're not gonna fit one of
them a minute or the pleasure of
nut-cracking yeah that's let's say Kelly
had one try anything that's right
because I've known for busting balls hey
guys if you liked what you saw today
wait to see what we got in the movie pit
let's take the black out January 29th be
there it's gonna be crazy
make that right little bird
[Music]